[Musique]
vous aurez peut-être reconnu ce célèbre
air de bach la toccata et fugue en ré
mineur qu'elles sont quelle image de
notre dame mais ces images sont les
derniers témoignages visuels qu'on a du
grand orgue notre dame de paris un ongle
meetic ou contrôle de ce mastodonte de
plus de 8000 tuyaux olivier latry un des
trois organiste titulaire de la
cathédrale
olivier latry entretient aussi un lien
tout particulier avec le québec avec
montréal puisqu'il a joué un rôle majeur
dans l'installation du grand orgue
pierre big de louer scène il est
d'ailleurs l'organisme émérite de louey
scène et ça fera cinq ans en mai que
l'orgue pierre béique donc séduit les
mélomanes
je les jouais plutôt à dresde en
allemagne à quelques heures d'un concert
avec l'orchestré philharmonique de
vienne
olivier latry bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60
bonsoir parmi les trésors perdus ou
abîmés dans cette grande histoire de
notre dame il ya les grandes orgues de
trois siècles d'histoire
comment avez vous vécu d'ailleurs vous
étiez à distance ne vous n'étiez pas à
part et comment avez vous vécu cette
épreuve normal bien entendu en fait je
suis arrivé hier à vienne
et au moment où je posais mes ben mes
bagages dans la chambre d'hôtel je
reçois un sms me disant notre-dame brute
qui croyais évidemment pas et j'ai vu
une photo accompagnant le sms avec les
flammes et sentiment incroyable irréel
que se passe-t-il et en fait on a allumé
tout de suite internet pour savoir ce
qui se passait et on s'est rendu compte
effectivement calcaterra le goulet je me
suis rendu compte très rapidement que le
les flammes à l'aise propagé très
rapidement parce que la charpente est
une charpente
ça a été une charpente de 800 ans donc
avec un bois extrêmement sec et ça a
brûlé extrêmement rapidement puisqu'en
quatre heures tout était complètement
détruit que savez-vous des dégâts
au grand orgue alors à priori et c'est
absolument miraculeux le grand orgue n'a
pas été trop touchés ni par les flammes
ni par les lances à eau des pompiers
parce que ça aurait pu être quand même
assez dramatique puisque si l'organe
aime pas le feu parce qu'évidemment ça
fait fondre les tuyaux le lourd peut
avoir des conséquences irréversibles sur
tous les campements en bois notamment
les sommiers qui contient des réserves
d'air pour faire sonner les tuyaux dont
vous êtes un peu rassuré est ce que vous
comptez accompagner la restauration des
grandes orgues
oui autant que faire se peut vous savez
on ne s'est jamais réellement ce qu'il
ya à faire
en tout cas maintenant c'est trop tôt
pour le dire devant il faudrait vraiment
qu'on puisse accéder à la tribune qu'on
puisse faire une expertise précise de
l'instrument de son état mais pour ça il
faut déjà pouvoir avoir l'autorisation
ce qui n'est pas le cas puisque rien
n'est sécurisé pour l'instant il ya
encore des pièces qui menacent de tomber
dans la cathédrale que ce soit un vote
que ce soit à l'extérieur dont le
périmètre est complètement sécurisé il
va falloir attendre un petit peu que
tout ça soit il a mobilisé qu'on puisse
enfin céder la tribune peut être la
semaine prochaine au grand à quoi
l'histoire de notre dame et liées
justement l'histoire de ces grandes
orgues mais parce que de grands noms
vont accompagner toutes les cérémonies
religieuses ou
nationale française que ce soit si on
monte un double dans le temps le sacre
de napoléon mais encore plus le sacre de
mariage d'henri iv
bon ça fait partie des événements
historiques en oeuvre notre la nuit
évidemment bien d'autres je pense au
technion de la libération au moment de
la libération de paris en 1944 les
enterrements des présidents qu'il soit
général de gaulle en 70 mitterrand 95
pour pidoux en 69 a eu énormément de
choses comme ça tout au long de 2 de
l'histoire de notre dame est bon
évidemment les victimes des attentats
qui ont été commémorés à notre dame que
celle il ya eu énormément de choses et
puis évidemment tout le service
liturgique qui évidemment la première
chose pour lequel lors des employés
parmi tous ces événements que vous avez
énumérés au fil des décennies vous y
êtes quand même depuis 1985
vous êtes arrivé à l'âge de 23 ans c'est
toute une histoire pour vous c'est parce
que jour et nuit si je comprends bien
des fois vous êtes là 4 heures du matin
pour pour pratiquer on se bouscule pour
pouvoir mettre les doigts sur le clavier
sur les touches
quel est le plus le souvenir le plus
émouvant que vous pouvez partager avec
nous vous savez notre dame est un lieu
exceptionnel et c'est exceptionnel parce
que il ne se passe pas une semaine sans
qu'il y ait un événement exceptionnel et
en fait je peux pas vous en citer
tellement ligue en à ce que je pourrais
vous dis c'est peut-être trois ou quatre
je pense par exemple la voilà
l'office pour les victimes du bataclan
qui a eu lieu en 2015 je pense aussi aux
ordinations prêtres tout simplement qui
a lieu tous les ans à notre dame où les
prêtres sont allongés sur le sol et la
sangle et panda litanie des saints
chante
priez pour nous on a l'impression que
c'est la cathédrale qui chante c'est
absolument fabuleux et on sont des
moments de grâce réellement mais ça peut
être tout simplement un serment
extraordinaire comme on l'a souvent
notre dame par l'un des chaplin et qui
va vous laisse vont plonger dans un dans
un abîme de réflexion il va vous donner
aussi des pistes intuitif pour pour
l'improvisation qui va suivre le service
est vraiment tellement de choses que ce
difficile à dire d'ailleurs on vous
décrit c'est votre renommée
internationale comme des meilleurs
improvisateurs sur l'orgue est
d'ailleurs au bataclan semble-t-il pour
cette cérémonie vous aviez improvisé une
marseillaise tout à fait émouvante qui
restent dans les mémoires de tous ceux
et celles qui étaient présents cela dit
les rangers devront se taire pour
quelques temps oui alors vous êtes en
deux et c'est un deuil j'imagine
important ne plus avoir accès avec le
grand orgue
j'imagine que vous êtes toujours sur la
grand tort vous vous allez sur les
autres aussi ou quoi je vous assure vous
ça peut m'arriver dans les jouets lors
du kiosque en fait notre dame est une
grande famille
il ya cinq organistes et trois au grand
orgue de choeur et quand l'un n'est pas
là une part a revu le on a il remplaçait
nombreux effectivement on joue les deux
instruments et le fait de les avoir
perdu un temps
[Musique]
c'est pas combien de temps est
évidemment extrêmement triste mais je
veux dire j'ai pas encore tout à fait
réalisé
oui comme en plus je ne suis pas à paris
je n'ai pas voulu notre dame dans cet
état qui n'avait vu que par par les
télévisions etc
ce difficile de deux mêmes en passant je
n'y arrive pas on dit que c'est un le
grand orgue est un des plus mythiques au
monde qu'est ce qu'il ya de particulier
ce grand tort ne serait-ce que son
ampleur je ne sais pas si c'est le bon
mot à utiliser mais parlez nous de ce
grand homme qui accompagnent votre vie
depuis toutes ces années
oui en fait le grand temps que notre
dame et déjà accompagné le pratiquement
la construction de la cathédrale il faut
imaginer qu'il a déconstruit l'an xiv
sens de cette tribune de pierre et qu'
il a été restauré depuis le début du
xviie siècle de tous les 25 ans par les
meilleurs facteurs du royaume de la
république après et est en fait chaque
facteur a toujours tenu à préserver ce
qui avait de meilleur c'est le précédent
donc évidemment le facteur est toujours
atteint un sommet de musicalité de
technique absolument incroyable et
c'était encore le cas jusqu'à la
dernière restauration il ya cinq ans
pascal grintas que ça doit serrer mes
trios
c'est le mythe yoyo 5 qui l'aviez 115
jeu un système informatique très
performant et surtout des possibilités
absolument un fini puisque je
qualifierais cet organe aux français à
savoir que c'est vraiment on peut y
jouer la musique du xviiie parce que
justement il ya encore tout le matériel
du xviiie siècle plus jouer la musique
symphonique évidemment puisque
l'ensemble de la structure de l'orgue
cavaillé-coll qui a restauré l'ordre
entre 1860 368 et et puis évidemment
toute la musique du xxème et du 20e
siècle
la prise d'armes à cran a déclaré
aujourd'hui qu'il espère que
notre dame soient reconstruites d'ici
cinq ans on le dit très optimiste
cela dit des mécènes je crois qu'on a
déjà amassé plus d'un milliard de
dollars vous vous rendez compte encore
en construction
votre réaction à ça mais ma réaction
c'est que évidemment je suis très
impatient j'espère que ça ira très vite
et je remercie évidemment tous les
donneurs déjà et tous ceux qui vont
donner et je dois dire que je je suis
extrêmement aussi touché par les
réactions des musiciens parce que les
musiciens ne parle pas de l'ordre qui
partent de la cathédrale aussi et ils
vont organiser partout dans le monde des
cancers pas seulement les organistes des
concerts pour justement trouver de
l'argent pour la cathédrale sa
restauration etc et par exemple j'ai eu
un appel téléphonique tout à l'heure du
bilan grâce de l'abc qui va organiser un
concert au profit les musiciens vont
jouer gratuitement au profit de la
restauration de la cathédrale
c'est absolument fabuleux et vous allez
être à montréal le 19 mai pour un
concert qui marque le les 5 le cinquième
anniversaire du grand orgue pierre mais
kalou sm7 organiste émérite de l'ouest
donc c'est un peu réconfortant aussi de
venir jouer sur un autre grand orgue et
c'est à montréal
oui c'est réconfortant je veux dire que
c'est réconfortant aussi de retrouver
des gens qui là aussi dans cette épreuve
m'ont beaucoup soutenu évidemment même
garou et toute son équipe mais également
quelques ados qui m'a très gentiment
envoyé un message désir
olivier latry merci beaucoup et bon
concert à vienne avec leur mère à dresde
mais avec l'orchestré philharmonique de
vienne demain soir merci beaucoup au
revoir merci non